Andrew Hawkins how are you sir how you
doing today hey thanks for coming on man
we just played your video by the way of
the what the little brawn thing the
thing you did in Will Rogers that's that
that's your that's that's good stuff man
you're bold to do that outside the
stadium you know what I'm trying my best
I feel like if you're not if you're not
going that hard you're not really trying
though yeah well you were trying and and
we loved it and I love the podcast as
well because you and Joe or chill your
reserved you don't mind doing like
relaxed interviews with the dude like
Tyler Lockett last week where you can
really dig in and find out more about a
guy more about what makes him tick and
and not just the football style I want
to get to the football stuff in a second
but just just for a second how much fun
do you have doing that podcast you know
I love the podcast because obviously as
I'm a retired player as is Joe the
biggest thing you miss is the locker
room but you don't miss getting hit you
don't miss you know running till you
throw up like you're good on that stuff
well she misses the camaraderie joking
with the guys and having that experience
so when we first had the idea for it
that's that was our thinking like hey it
made if nothing else we'll do this every
week on the phone why not put a
microphone in the room and let everybody
else listen and that's how we try to
keep it you talk about the interviews we
want guys to come on and feel like oh
man we're just having a conversation in
the locker room and it makes it fun and
people liking and enjoy being a fly on
the wall for those conversations well
take us in the locker room Andrew
whether it's the Giants or or the
Raiders all right two teams that have
made trades with the trade deadline
coming up on Tuesday what is it like
knowing that your coaches and GM's have
in essence said we're shutting it down
yeah that's uh it's it's tough
especially for the veteran players
younger players typically don't really
know what's going on quite yet but for
the older guys it is tough to show up to
work and and feel like you know the
focus is not on winning as many games
anymore because that's to train all
offseason for that's what you're you
know you shape your entire schedule
around like you don't take vacations you
you wake up early in the morning you
want to be the first one up your track
drop in
tire year under the guise of hey we're
gonna get in here and we're trying to
maximize on value when as many games as
possible
so once the decisions are starting to be
made that go against that it's extremely
hard not to check out you know because a
guy understands that there is no next
year I may not be here next year I may
not be playing next year so when an
organization starts to look towards the
future it is a little disheartening for
the veteran guy talking to Andrew
Hawkins the hawk portion of the tomahawk
pod podcast beg your pardon oh so does
ESPN and snapchat as well let's talk
about trades we we were thrown around
the idea I don't if you heard this
Andrew but the the Rockets allegedly
offered four number ones for Jimmy
Butler which is just mind-blowing
is there a player yeah four number ones
is there an NFL player that could get
even close to that oh man is it NFL
player that can get close to four number
one if I'm a GM there's not a player on
earth unless his LeBron at like 25 years
old he wants to go into football
I'm not giving four number ones up for
anyone what would you give up right now
for Derek Carr like if somebody called
Jon Gruden says we will make you an
offer that you cannot refuse what would
that also be I would give a one out for
their car I would give a one up I don't
know if I would give two one maybe a one
into two because we have seen Derek Carr
at like a at his highest level I mean he
wouldn't got hurt that that great season
he was having I believe with 2015 he
would have been the MVP right and would
you give up a first-round pick for an
MVP I would I just because there's so
many craft and I played in Cleveland man
we've had first-round quarterback at the
first-round quarterback that didn't work
out not this quarter we had first-round
players that weren't even on the team
within two and three seasons so I don't
want to say I unders all you a
first-round pick but it does all depend
on which coach it is at all it does not
depend on what GM it is to be able to
maximize giving that up and being able
to build around them if you give up too
many first rounders or you give up too
much you kind of handicap yourself and
not being able to get the value out of
that player that you're looking for
because you're playing with a shorter
deck the perfect example Corey Coleman
2016 first round pick is already gone
that's exactly I mean it happened it's
unfortunate but it you know first round
pick Singh and having that kind of
inventory and cup compensate it doesn't
matter if you can't pick the right guys
exactly which is what the Raiders now
have to do they have five first-round
picks coming up in the next two seasons
all right speaking of Cleveland I have
not listened to the full episode yet but
I saw the thing you guys tweeted out can
you tell the Cody Kessler terrelle pryor
story because Cody Kessler came in last
week for Blake bortles and like you
actually played better than Blake
bortles but now he is back to being the
number two and bortles are still the guy
at least for now
as they go to London but you work Cody
kessler's teammate yep so Cody Kessler
was a rookie in 2016 I believe was
drafted him and I think that year we had
RG three we had Josh McCown or we got it
you know rotating see that quarterback
sometimes we bring every time a time
long story short win a game somebody
gets hurt the next guy gets hurt and
somehow it's Cody's article he's the
rookie never play before the game plan
going in was not for him to play you
know and so he gets really really
nervous to the point that you know you
have to take it any rep third and see
what I don't realize it's very string
quarterbacks they don't do anything all
week because the first team guy takes
all the rest of the starters in practice
and then the second team guy he takes
the scout team reps against the starting
deeper to the third drink I literally
just he does drills for like a period of
practice and then he doesn't do anything
for the rest of the week so here we are
with this guy is about to go in having
not taken any reps he's a rookie still
trying to get the offense down and it
was like later in the game so I think
someone was like I would look but I
can't throw him in we have terrelle
pryor on the roster who's now playing
wire okay let's put in TP today go to
throw Bryden HTP we need you to go start
taking some snaps
so-and-so is hurt and I think you got it
go in at quarterback and terrelle pryor
looks at him and he says I'm not going
in and they're like what even again you
don't pay me enough to play quarterback
I'm a receiver now if you wanted me to
play quarterback that's another cop
we should ask but I'm a wide receiver it
actually end of it and everybody's mouth
was got on the floor all the receivers
are last because we understood it we're
like true it's right if you want to play
quarterback editor that's a higher price
and Cody Kessler had to go in I don't
know if Cody ended up going I think Josh
McCown may have liked toughed it out rub
some some special sauce and the shorter
he was going back in but well I don't
know if I was gonna go there but let's
go there is that why terrelle pryor has
had trouble hanging on to a job since he
turned out we'll look to be at the time
a pretty darn good free agent contract
to stay with the Browns you know it's a
gamble it's a gamble I don't know if
it's the reason why he's had trouble I
think more than anything it's like you
know it's a different world to be able
to transition from a quarterback you
ever see but first off there's one of
two thousand athletes that would ever be
able to do it and happen to be one of
those guys but in that you don't change
your mentality of a quarterback right so
there's so what do you think is a big
contract what you think is a great deal
looks different from a receiver
perspective to a quarterback perspective
or even like what your command is in a
room what your what your role is in a
room when a team is it's just different
it's not something that I don't think TP
was used to because he studied when he
would be playing wide receiver he would
be making suggestions on what passes are
throwing the goal line or he will be
telling us what the tackle is gonna do
or they track their running back need to
take it I'm like yes you are flooding
your mind with information you no longer
need trust me that stuff does not matter
anymore stop looking at it stop looking
at what the DM doing stop looking at
what the linebackers are doing this is
all you need to focus on but again he's
been taught his whole life to do it that
way and it's hard to turn off and that's
booked on the field and off the field
Andrew Hawkins one last thing when asked
about the Rams no one here in LA because
we had better things to worry about
right now is thinking about them going
undefeated
because the last four games are low
right now the next four games rather
Green Bay at New Orleans Seattle at home
and then Kansas City on the road in
Mexico City but should we be thinking
about them going undefeated do you think
they have a logician
I think they're an incredible team I
can't say that I watch them and I think
they're going to be able to run the
table you know I like getting they have
an incredible collection of players Sean
McVeigh does an incredible job of
getting the most out of those guys with
so many different personalities in the
locker room that I don't think a lot of
coaches would even be able to have a
control on but because Sean is so well I
think he's maximizing what they have but
I don't think that they're going to feed
it it's just it's so hard and today's
NFL and I did the dishes were childhood
offices every week never know who the
problem who's gonna have a great game
and that's the beauty of professional
football well not especially not this
early in the season I'm not prepared to
take it one baby all right my last thing
I lied you guys would've been in you and
Joe Thomas last week who had more coach
swag 30-something coach swag between
Shaun McVeigh and Kyle Shanahan did we
ever ever decide on a winner I don't
know this is what I mean we were a
little biased or scowl because not only
do we get to see the swag on TV we know
the behind the room swag we've seemed to
do dance we've seen the guys celebrate
touchdown sweet-hearted playlists which
is heavily little Wayne so we're a
little biased towards the Shanahan team
but I did see shamans ready for the
flight not too long ago and thought to
myself I've never seen a head coach with
that kind of swag of my life though we
don't have a consensus on it I'm buying
sword and a ham but the decision is
still up in the air
all right well McVeigh got in last week
but for what that's worth
Kyle Shanahan's not dealing with a full
deck there with all those injuries in
San Francisco Andrew Hawkins the
tomahawk podcast downloaded now watch
him as well on snapchat on SportsCenter
as well through ESPN
we appreciate you picking up the phone
my friend enjoy your football weekend of
course I appreciate then talk to you got
it and rockin the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience